(man) the sharks are back,
and they're looking for
the best products
and Businesses
America has to offer.
The only thing that really
matters--what is it? Money.
Hopeful entrepreneurs
come to the shark tank
seeking an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
I just really need to succeed.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
if you can teach me
how to play the guitar...
I promise you I can right now.
And fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I'm gonna beat
this jerk's offer.
Here comes
her blood-sucking offer.
What a witch.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for
or they'll walk away
with Nothing.
There's nothing
that can stop me.
It's actually about
$100 million a year market.
It's sink or Swim.
Love this pitch.
I smell failure.
Who are the sharks?
They're five self-made
filthy rich Investors.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 Billion.
Barbara Corcoran
turned a $1,000 loan
into a real estate Empire
worth hundreds of millions
in the shark-filled city
of Manhattan.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-made
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas Mavericks.
First into the shark tank
is Travis Perry
with a product inspired
by his daughter.
♪♪♪
.My name is Travis Perry.
I'm from dothan, alabama,
and I have invented a product
that allows you to play
the guitar instantly.
Put that finger there, okay.
Now strum the bottom four.
Ooh.
That hurt your fingers,
didn't it?
That finger's got boo-boo.
The main reason that people quit
is frustration
and finger pain.
Even Brady,
my 8-year-old daughter,
was gonna quit guitar.
And I decided it's high time
that somebody
did something about it.
The area of the country
that I live
was hit pretty hard
with the economic downturn.
One thing that was
very important to me
was to keep the manufacturing
and the jobs in the U.S.
It means a lot to me
to give back,
so to be able to turn around
and offer jobs
to people that had lost jobs
is as important
as the product itself.
I really have to get a deal
from the sharks
'cause we're at a stage of--
a corvette.
We're like a race car.
We've won
all the preliminary races.
We're on the starting line,
and we're running out of gas.
♪♪♪
My name is Travis Perry.
My product is chordbuddy.
I've come to the shark tank
to ask for $125,000
for a 10% equity stake
in my business.
My love is music.
I have taught thousands
of people to play the guitar.
Sadly,
I've seen thousands quit.
The guitar is the most popular
instrument in the world,
but yet it is
one of the most frustrating.
We all want to play the guitar
for one reason.
You know what it is.
To meet chicks!
(sharks laugh)
But what if a product existed
where you could push a button
and play a song
and learn the guitar
with no frustration?
Well, sharks,
there's no "What if."
it exists,
and it is
the award-winning chordbuddy.
There are four buttons.
It plays "G" ...
(strums chord)
"D"...
"C"...
(strums chord)
and "E" Minor.
With those four chords,
you can pays
hundreds of thousands of songs.
♪♪♪
Y'all, that's done
with one button.
One finger.
(strums chord)
But are you really learning
how to play the guitar
by pushing a single button?
Why are you learning anything?
Oh, man.
The question
I was waiting for.
It is a cheat, I'll be honest--
unless it does this...
you pull that out.
Now...
instead
of pressing a button....
(strums chord)
You're really playing a chord.
We have a patented
2-month learning system
and a dvd that takes you
every step of the way
from removing your first tab
to removing your last one.
(Robert) So you slowly take off
the different colors?
Yeah. Now you're playing
what the red one did.
Where it used to be. Got it.
Where it used to be.
How much does it cost,
Travis?
Retail $49.95.
(mark) What's it cost to make?
Initially, it cost us $9.
Now we're down to $7.
So if you just wanna
pick up chicks,
it's $50 plus the cost
of the guitar. (laughs)
How cheap is that? (laughs)
Travis, whenever I drive
down the street with my girls
and a good guitar riff comes on,
I wanna be a rock star so bad.
If you could teach me
how to play the guitar...
I promise you I can right now.
Let's do it.
(chuckles) Okay.
(imitates Elvis Presley)
Thank you. Thank you very much.
All right, I'll play,
you sing.
Smash the red one.
(normal voice) the red one?
Uh-huh.
(strums chord)
♪ Amazing grace ♪
Green. Just the green.
Just the green there.
♪ How sweet... ♪
back to blue.
♪ The sound ♪
oh!
Whoo! We're jamming!
♪ That saved a wretch-- ♪
whoo!
♪ A wretch ♪
go to red.
Red?
♪ Like me ♪
(strums chord)
(mark) All right!
Whoo!
Y'all, what you've
just seen him do
would take at least two Months.
That's True.
Have you sold any of this?
Yes. In one month,
we did $150,000.
How?
Internet and we set up
eight local music stores.
Local where?
In--in L.A.--
Lower Alabama.
(all laugh)
(Robert) Travis,
how'd you come up with this?
I was teaching
my 8-year-old daughter Brady
to play a song.
She was fixin' to become one of
the 6 out of 10 that quit,
and I said, "Brady, I've had
an IDEA for 31 years
of a magical device, and you can
press a button and play a song."
She looked at me in the eyes
and she says,
"daddy, invent that for me,"
and I did.
You must be a great Dad.
Thanks.
♪♪♪
Well, we got through that,
didn't we?
(laughs)
(Kevin) Travis, look,
I buy you're a great Dad.
You're very funny, too.
(laughs)
and maybe you've
got something here.
But I wanna go back
to the money, because that's--
in the end, that's what
it's about, my friend.
You're telling me that I can buy
10% of this product--
it's not really a company yet--
for $125,000,
which means I have to
look at it and say,
"This idea is worth
$1.25 million."
That's right.
You walk me through
why that's the case, Travis.
How much have you done in sales
since you've started?
Since We've started--
a half a million.
You've collected the cash
on that?
Absolutely.
You brought in
half a million in sales?
And I've got--I've got P.O.S
for another $110,000
that we're fulfilling now.
Purchase orders?
That's right.
How do you think
you can sell this year, Travis?
Well... and the only reason
I hesitate, I--
the largest retail chain...
don't hesitate.
In the country is giving us
a P.O. In two weeks.
Have you guesstimated what
their sell through is gonna be?
They've--they've told us
50 per store.
How many stores do they have?
They have--
they have 5,000 stores.
Who is it?
Sam's.
Wow.
(daymond) Sam's clubs.
Let me ask you this.
Why do you need $125,000 today?
We're building right now
at my plant in dothan, alabama.
And by the way, this is
a 100% U.S.A.-Made Product.
Congratulations for that.
That's important.
Thank you.
Why aren't you making it
in China?
I want it to be U.S.A.
I think that's the downfall
of our country.
I bet you they can make that
for 80 cents.
They probably can.
Yeah, you can squeeze
another Nickel out...
it's not a Nickel.
But it--but it's--a dollar.
Sometimes it feels good to
do the right thing, so I'm--
he comes from a territory's
that's been destroyed.
I think the people need
the jobs.
Good for you, Travis.
They are--yeah, they do.
Good for you.
All right, Travis,
I think you have something
really interesting here, but...
I don't like your valuation,
my friend.
Sure.
But I believe if it works,
it'll get its place in retail
in places like
guitar center.
I've lived with Guitars
my whole life.
I got a lot of 'em.
I play guitar.
So I'm gonna
make you an offer.
I'll give you $125,000...
for 20%,
and I'll personally endorse
the product.
I'll do an infomercial
for you.
Put my face on the box--whatever
you wanna do for $12 million.
Travis, that's how vain he is.
That's how self-important he is
he thinks that his picture
on the box is gonna sell it.
Yeah, he does.
(Robert laughs)
He does.
Hey, he's big in L.A.--
Lower Alabama.
(laughs)
Hey, listen, I'm up here
for a reason, my friend.
Don't make jokes about it.
(daymond) Travis, sir...
I think I'm gonna match
Voldemort's offer...
but I think you'll know
that I'm a better partner
so I'm gonna do
the same $125,000 for 20%.
This guy cannot play guitar,
by the way.
I think that's the Point.
Yeah. Barbara,
are you in or you out?
I'm thinking about it.
Mark, all right you in
or you out?
I'm thinking.
(daymond)
Are you in or you're out?
(Robert) Thinking.
Oh, my gosh.
Travis, you got two offers
on the table,
and those offers
will soon be gone.
So while everybody else
is thinking,
would you like to make
a decision?
♪♪♪
Travis has two offers
on the table,
but the other three sharks
are still in.
I'll give you $125,000
for 20%,
and I'll personally endorse
the product.
I'm gonna do the same.
$125,000, 20%.
(Robert) same offer.
Same--same offer.
(Kevin) same offer.
Endorsement?
I happen to represent
a lot of the biggest celebrities
in the world.
(Kevin) But they're not gonna
get you that for free.
We may work that in.
You're gonna get
a free celebrity endorsement?
Absolutely.
Wow.
I don't think so.
Which celebrity, daymond?
Don't worry about it.
I do worry about it,
if that's swaying him.
I wouldn't promise 'em
without speaking to 'em.
I can do that, 'cause I
represent them, so that's--
oh, you're
in the agent business?
You know, the good news is,
I represent me,
and I just spoke to myself,
and I'm okay with it.
(laughs)
I'm vacillating, Travis.
I mean, I like
what you're doing.
Okay.
I love the fact that
you're made in the U.S.A.,
but I'm not quite sure that
you're gonna be able to scale--
you're gonna have
to be that guy
that goes on the road show
all the time,
and how old are
your kids now?
10, 3, and 1.
That's part of the problem,
right?
That's tough,
so... I'm out.
I have an offer for you.
Okay.
I'm going
to beat this jerk's offer.
You don't want to go
with him.
(laughs)
Oh, you know, what a witch.
I'm gonna give you--
I'm going to give you $175,000
for the same 20%...
with the contingency that
$50,000 of that money
is used
to make an infomercial,
and you know why?
Because the best thing
you have going about you
is not just your product
but you,
and that's
the only missing piece here.
You've got to figure a way
to take you
and multiply it times 1,000,
and there's no better medium
than television.
I would not guarantee you're
gonna be in an infomercial
until you've rolled out
retail.
Travis, you--
don't let an investor tell you
how to run your business.
No, I have--
Travis, infomercials is
just another way
to sell the product.
Another way?
That might be part
of the future.
It puts him in--it puts him
in every living room.
Oh, please.
Travis, here's an offer.
I'm just a redneck
from croatia,
like you're a redneck
from alabama.
I'll give you the $125,000
for... 20%.
Same offer.
I don't think you need
more cash.
I don't think you need to do
the infomercial right now.
Oh, really? You want
to keep him locked up.
I'll give you
the $125,000 for 20%.
I'm the only one here
who wants to be a rock star
and can't play,
so I'm living up to a promise
I made to my daughter.
(Kevin) Let's summarize
what we've got, okay?
We've got
croatian rock star wannabe guy--
$125,000 for 20%.
(Barbara laughs)
but am I not the market?
And--what?
(Travis) You are the market.
$125,000 for 20%.
We've got
"I want to control your life
in every way known to man"--
Barbara.
Not at all.
He's the lead.
I just want to help him.
Um, I'm just pointing out
what you do want, and that's--
$175,000 gets you 20%
with her deal,
but a nightmare from hell
to work with.
We know that.
Really?
I'm a straight shooter here.
I just want to give you
some money.
I love guitar,
and if you want my endorsement,
you get it for free,
and daymond has
some nebulous guy in the sky--
we don't know who it is--
that maybe will endorse this,
but he'll do a--the same deal,
$125,000 for 20%.
You're in a really rare spot
right now, Travis.
Not often in the shark tank
do you get
four rock-solid Offers.
Travis...
those are pr-pretty good offers.
In fact--
this is a no-brainer.
I've offered you $50,000 more
to get you to where
you need to go,
to get your personality on tv.
People are gonna fall
in love with You.
Look, I can get you on tv
in two seconds. It's Nothing.
Look at the offers
you're getting.
It's your personality that
they're falling in love with.
Look, I'm just
a lonely shark here
trying to play the guitar,
baby.
This is so hard.
(strums notes)
Robert, would you...
sweeten your offer some way?
I'll put the $50,000 aside
to produce an infomercial,
if we make that decision.
So it's $125,000 cash
with $50,000 in escrow
for an infomercial?
Absolutely.
'cause I'm gonna quit
this shark thing, baby.
I'm gonna go on the road.
Me and you. Me and you.
I'm gonna become a rock star.
I'm talking about a duo
in the redneck riviera.
Me, too, Baby.
(mark and Barbara laugh)
do we have a deal?
Do we have a deal?
Travis.
Robert, the deal's with you.
Damn. Ohh.
Whoo!
(laughs)
Oh, baby, I'm gonna be--
(both) Yeah!
(all laugh)
baby!
I'm gonna be a rock star!
All right.
I can't watch.
That is Awesome. Thank you.
(off-key)
♪ Well, Travis and I ♪
♪ we did ourselves a deal ♪
♪ got a deal in the tank ♪
♪ we got a deal
in the tank ♪
♪ and we're gonna
make millions ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ millions ♪
whoo!
We got it!
(woman) Whoo!
(laughs)
Yeah!
Ohh.
(Travis) My family now will be
financially stable.
(voice breaks) This is
a life-changing moment for me.
♪♪♪
Last season
Shawn Davis left the shark tank
without a deal
for his shrimp Burger company,
cbs foods.
I'd be buying more into you,
'cause you're a great guy,
than buying
into the business.
I'm out.
Let's see how he's doing now.
(motor rumbles)
♪♪♪
I'm down here
in Chauvin, louisiana
at the indian Ridge
shrimp processing plant,
where if I'm making
the perfect shrimp Burger,
I need the perfect shrimp,
right out of the gulf of Mexico.
This is what we have today.
So what have we got?
When I was on "Shark tank,"
I didn't get a deal.
I was tremendously disappointed,
but as soon as I came back,
I was welcomed
by So much support,
thousands of e-mails.
A lot of investors called me
and wanted to offer cbs foods
a chance.
I even got an INVESTMENT better
than I was asking for
on the "Shark tank."
Before the "Shark tank,"
my Earnings were
a little bit over $30,000
with the shrimp Burger.
Cbs foods.
This year our projected sales
are over $5 million.
We're slated to go
to over 2,000 grocery stores
across America.
I'm gonna need you to keep
the shrimp coming, man.
Yeah, that's it.
The "Shark tank" Saved
my business
and also saved my life.
I owe them everything.
(ship Horn Honks)
♪♪♪
Next into the tank is
Pat Mccarthy,
who is hoping to entice
the sharks
with their favorite bait.
Whoo!
Oh, yeah, baby!
All right. Make it rain.
I like the look of this.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Pat Mccarthy,
and I'm the founder
of liquid money.
I'm seeking $100,000
in exchange for 5%
of my company.
We all know that sharks have
an amazing sense of smell.
In fact, just one drop of blood
in 1,000 gallons of water
can send them
into an uncontrollable frenzy.
Well, humans also can get
excited by smell,
and there's one scent
in particular
that opens our gills
and gets us circling.
(sniffs)
the smell of money, baby.
It's the smell of money.
Can I get an amen?
Amen.
(mark and Barbara laugh)
Amen!
Good.
Preach, brother. Preach!
(Robert and Kevin laugh)
so I got to thinking,
if such a fragrance can hold
so much power,
then why hasn't anyone
bottled it?
(mouths word)
Well, I have.
Introducing money,
the fragrance of success,
the sweet smell
of greenbacks...
(sharks laugh)
Available in Two forms--
his money and her money.
(mark and Barbara laugh)
My fragrance is based
on three core elements--
cotton, silk, and linen.
These are
the same three ingredients
you find in cold, hard cash.
Folks, we know
money can't buy happiness,
but who cares...
(chuckles)
When you can smell like
a million bucks?
Now my models are going
to bring you some money.
Now how's that
for a change of pace?
Love this Pitch.
That's wonderful.
I love it.
Thank you.
You know, this is
the fragrance of success.
(sniffs) actually it smells
pretty Good.
Do you know own that name?
Is it trademarked?
I do, and I was
really surprised,
but I got it.
In what category?
For fragrances.
Really?
(daymond) Pat, have you sold
this product already?
I have.
What are your sales
annually?
Well, annual sales are
$52,000, year to date.
What retailers carry it now?
So in the retail space,
I have--
which is one of my challenges
right now, Kevin--
oh, you're not getting
into retail, Pat.
I'm not--I'm not--
I-I've got--
right. I've got it
in very limited Retail.
Isn't the truth about
this business,
the--one of the highest margin
businesses on earth,
but large box retailers,
where 90% of this is sold,
would never give you
any space
'cause they protect it like
drug dealers protect their turf?
No. No, they will give him
the space,
but they'll give him the space
at $1.5 million...
exactly.
Because the JUICE only costs
a dollar to make
and $50 to sell.
That's my Point.
He's never gonna get
any distribution.
But I am talking to C.V.S.
Right now.
They are very interested.
How much have you invested
in this company?
So I've put about $50,000
into this product.
(Robert) I don't think
that's very much.
How'd you--how'd you
come up with this?
So I went to an a.T.M.
The bills were so new that
they actually stuck together.
They were--there was
a unique fragrance to them.
I didn't realize money really
had its OWN unique smell.
It definitely does.
You don't have enough of it.
That's the problem.
(laughs)
and then I read this study,
uh, about japan,
where they actually pump
that fragrance
through the vents...
really?
To increase
worker productivity.
They do it here, too.
It's called
ambient scenting.
It's actually about
$100 million a year market
and growing.
Well, you've done research
on that market.
That sounds like a far different
and more enticing market...
Mm. Definitely.
Than selling perfume.
Have you looked at piping in
the scent of your money
in--in
an ambient environment?
I-I haven't, but I have been
approached by banks
to use it as a gift.
When you open an account
with the bank,
they actually will
give you--
give you your money back?
(laughs)
Will give you money back.
That's exactly right.
Pat, that's all good,
but there's a little bit
of a problem here.
You gotta get huge distribution.
You gotta buy your way in.
This is what daymond was
talking about.
You need millions of dollars,
so...
so I put out one press release
on this product.
This product exploded
worldwide.
It's in Poland, croatia,
China--
$50,000 in Sales.
$50,000 in sales is not
an explosion.
It is in Croatia.
Uh, it's an implosion.
But it's
a very unique product, right?
The--you buy this product
because of the name,
and you come back
because of the fragrance.
(daymond) This business
is solely on advertising,
and $100,000
will only buy you
one page in one of the books
that the big guys are in.
Pat, how much money do you have
left to put in this business?
Frankly I don't--
I really don't want to put
any more money into it.
So this is
your big play here.
You gotta walk out of the tank
with the cash in your pocket.
Absolutely.
Correct. This is it.
(daymond)
So why would you offer us...
This--
5%...
right.
For $100,000?
That means you are saying
the value of your company
is $2 million.
Well, I'm gonna go back
to my Point.
You're talking
about a $32 billion Market.
Seven out of ten are
for gifts.
Pat, you've broke--you've broken
the Cardinal rule for me.
Yeah.
When someone starts off with,
"the market is billions,
and if I only get
a small percentage..."
Yeah.
I'll be okay."
That's always a red flag...
right. Right.
Because you don't have
enough confidence
in your product to dive
all-in.
Now that's not fair, Mark.
That's not fair.
What? I don't care.
If y-you want my money,
and you want
a $2 million valuation...
right. Right.
And if you don't believe
enough to sell money,
then you're a want-repreneur,
not an entrepreneur,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Now you said,
money can't buy you happiness.
I've been rich,
and I've been poor.
Right.
Rich is better.
I agree.
By the way,
is this real money?
That is real money.
What?
It is?
Aren't you going to jail
for chopping up money, Pat?
Wow. That's not right.
(chuckles) Yeah.
Yeah, that's actual
shredded U.S. Currency.
Where'd you get it from?
I buy that from
the department of Treasury.
Well, that's cool.
Is there a business in taping
this back together again?
(sharks laugh)
(chuckles) No, there isn't.
I don't know.
No, that would be illegal.
We can't do that.
Look, Pat, the only thing
of value I see is that you--
you've got the name "Money"
in the fragrance Category.
Good for you.
Everything else is insane.
I love money.
I'm emotionally involved
with it, and it loves me, too,
so it really breaks my heart
to have to say this to you,
but I'm out.
I know that 75% of all
fragrances are sold duty-free,
and the rest,
you need backing.
I like
that idea of the license...
so...
I'll give you
the $100,000 for 80%...
and I'll go license the name,
and we'll make a lot
of real money.
I-I think 80% is--
is quite high.
(mark) Just remember,
100% of Nothing is
still Nothing.
20% of something growing
and big...
he's offering to put himself
to work for you
and pay you to do it.
That never happens.
Pat, I must say, I think
your packaging is Great.
Thank you.
Perfect, okay?
But that doesn't smell
like money to me.
You know what?
I get $500 a week out
of that cash machine,
'cause they always
give it to me in New $50s...
right. Right.
So I purposely do it.
Yes.
I always smell the money
before I put it
in my wallet...
right.
So I really know
what money smells like.
It's subtle.
This is not subtle.
Even though you look
like Robert Redford...
(laughs)
I'm out.
(daymond) you have an offer
on the table.
(sighs)
80% of the company?
Yes.
I mean, I really would like
to have control of this company.
Pat, it disturbs me a little bit
that we had to show you
the obvious path,
which was licensing.
I don't think this is
a perfume product.
I think this is
a licensing product.
I don't smell the money.
I smell failure with
the strategy you have today,
and for that, I'm out.
Just like money, when there's
not enough buyers,
my money becomes more valuable,
and just like real money,
you have a depreciating asset
right now.
Right. Right.
So unless you give me
an answer right now,
it's going up to 85%.
(chuckles) 80%?
So, again, I think that
this market has
tremendous potential.
80% is too much.
I can't do 80%.
Then I'm out.
There goes the money.
(laughs)
(Pat) I have no regrets,
turning down Daymond's offer.
The 80% was just out of Line.
♪♪♪
Next into the shark tank is
Kyle Rainey,
with a product he hopes will
light up the Sharks.
Hello. My name is Kyle Rainey,
from baton rouge, louisiana.
I am creator
of tail lightz.
I am here today seeking
$50,000
in exchange for 50%
of my business.
There are currently
no products like mine
on the market today,
but soon my product will
be catching on
as a hot new Trend
in fashion,
with people of all ages
bringing attention
to their greatest assets.
(man) ♪ Shake your body ♪
(laughs)
(Barbara) Okay.
I hope those aren't
your daughters, Kyle.
One's my niece.
(laughs)
You just ruined it for me.
Kyle, I'll give you $50,000
to turn the other way.
All right.
(all chuckle)
Once these hit the market,
no one will want to be caught
without their tail lightz on.
Tail Lightz are
attachable lighted designs
for Jean pockets.
Anyone can easily attach
or detach tail lightz
to the back pocket
of any jeans, shorts,
or, Heck, even your hat,
purse, or backpack.
There are
tiny, strong magnets
on the back
of each lighted design,
which hold it in place
no matter what you put it on.
We can tailor our designs
towards all age groups.
Designs like the Smiley face
and sports themes
will appeal towards
young kids,
and our fun phrase designs,
like "Sassy britches,"
"Rock star," and "Drama Queen,"
will Appeal towards
girls and women of all ages.
The possibilities are
endless.
My Products are currently
in the design phase
with working prototypes.
With your partnership,
I will be able to design
slimmer Retail-ready products
and packaging...
thank you.
So that tail lightz will
soon be lighting up
every Retail store
across the country.
So who is ready to partner
with an experienced inventor
and light things up?
Who's ready?
I'm ready.
That's it? You're in?
That's it?
All right. Let's go.
I am ready to go out.
(Robert) Oh. (laughs)
(laughs)
I'm out.
So, Barbara,
you're really out?
Yes. Would you like
to know why?
Do you want to--
do you want to make
a speech about why? Sure.
I wouldn't mind. Yeah.
Sure.
First off, sitting on this
would be painful...
yep.
On the back seat
of your pants.
Secondly, I bet
they don't wash well
when you make the mistake
of forgetting to take them off.
Third, I think the designs
on these feel dated to me.
But other than that,
I love the idea.
(Robert and mark laugh)
guys, what do you have
on your tush?
Sassy Britches.
Sassy britches.
Would you go on a date
wearing "Sassy Britches"?
um...
you see, that's
the problem, right?
You've got your core audience
right here,
but do you think
it's going to catch on
and catch fire
and lighten all of America?
I just don't see it.
Well, keep in mind that
these prototypes are bulky.
I realize that, and that's
why I'm here today.
I need the funding to get
to that next level.
There's other products
like this out there.
They do make--
I have not seen
any other products
that combine the lighting
and the design.
You've never seen
a button that glows?
Not in a-a Patch,
with the lighting like this,
that are detachable
and can be removed and--
but there's nothing proprietary
about it, right?
If I wanted to knock it off,
why couldn't I just go
and get this manufactured
and compete with you?
Because there's nothing
to stop me from doing it.
Well, I have
two patents pending.
And what are
your patents for?
The patents are for
the detachable lighted design,
and then the other patent is
for the fashion line
that I created, which is called
twinkle cheeks.
So what do you do
for a living, Kyle?
I'm a Mr. Mom,
I'm an artist,
and I'm an inventor.
Okay, and does your wife
make a lot of money?
My wife, uh, has financially
supported our family
for 13 years now.
She's wonderful.
She is the most amazing woman
Anybody could ask for.
So she's basically funding
your goal to have one of these
work out for you.
That's right,
and I am at the point
in my life
where I just really need
to succeed,
so that she doesn't have
to work so hard.
Okay, Kyle, this is not going
to be the one that succeeds.
I think you've got
that message loud and clear.
We've all seen this.
There's nothing proprietary
about it.
I'm out.
I gotta tell ya,
Barbara's right.
It looks dated.
I'm out.
I've seen ten of these
in the last year
that either were already
on the market
or already doing sales.
I'm out.
Kyle,
the important thing is,
it doesn't matter
how many times you fail.
All it takes is one,
then everybody can call you
an overnight success...
(chuckles) That's True.
So don't quit...
mm-hmm.
Because We've all been
laughed at.
I know I've been laughed at,
and my biggest hits have been
the ones people thought
were most likely to fail.
You are...
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you for your time.
(daymond and Barbara)
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Good luck, Kyle.
Thank you.
(Kyle) It's pretty humiliating.
I'm just kinda wondering,
you know,
did I make the right move
in taking it here?
But, you know, you--
you can't live life like that.
You just have to try
and--and keep on going.
That wife is incredible.
Either that
or he's a good dad,
and she's smart
for letting him
keep on doing it.
That's True.
He's home looking
after the Kids.
That's the best job
in the world.
♪♪♪
Next up is Megan Cummins,
who has a cheeky twist
to a common product.
Hi.
My name is Megan Cummins.
My company is you smell,
and I'm seeking
a $55,000 investment
in exchange for 20%
of the company.
You smell is
a new luxury soap brand
That's a breath
of fresh air
in An oftentimes snooty
marketplace.
It has delicious fragrances
and a vibrant personality.
You smell started out
as a class project
back in college.
I was taking
a package design class,
and I had free rein to develop
any product I wanted.
I wanted to develop something
that had personality,
and what instantly came
to mind was you smell.
I didn't want to be blinded
by, um, excitement,
so I decided to do
a trial run to test the market.
I had about 1,200 bars made
in 2 custom fragrances--
Lemon verbena
and Lavender Mint.
Um, I brought you all
some samples,
so you can smell them.
So look at this. It says,
"you smell" On the front,
and you flip it around,
and it says, "Lemon."
You smell like a Lemon,
Barbara.
(chuckles)
"Like a Lemon."
It's cute.
Since I haven't opened,
uh, my doors yet
to actually have a revenue,
I have tested the market.
I actually told
a few blogs--
Oh, so you haven't sold
any of you smell yet?
No, I'm still pre-venture,
actually.
So you have bars just sitting
in a warehouse or what?
No, actually I had those made
and already got rid of them,
sending them out
to different companies,
and then almost overnight
it ended up going international,
you know--new York,
L.A., and Canada, australia--
did you sell them,
or you gave them away?
I did sell them,
'cause I wanted to see
how much people were willing
to pay for them.
And what did you learn?
And what--Yeah.
Well, people were
selling them,
surprisingly,
for between $7 to $12 a bar,
but I also found that
there were a lot of companies,
some very big names,
that, um, actually wanted it
to be more like
$4.50, $5.00.
So what kind of names?
When you say big names,
who are they?
The biggest one would be
urban outfitters.
They asked, you know,
how fast I could have
stuff made,
in what quantities,
and then what
the price point would be.
Megan, what--what is this?
Is this a paper product,
a paper version of the soap?
Yeah, it--it's actually--
it's paper soap,
um, so it's smaller
than a little packet of gum.
You can fit it
in your purse, your pocket.
I've never seen
that before.
It's something
that would be an--you know,
an impulse buy
at a register.
And you sell it for...
the soap bars are going to be
roughly about 80 cents.
Retail, that would be
about $2.25.
Not bad margins.
Great margins.
I like it.
Megan, if I invest
in your company here--
I'm a slave driver, right,
and I demand a lot,
so I'd be invest--
oh, my goodness.
You're gonna love me.
(mark and Barbara laugh)
I'm probably
the most tenacious person
you're ever going to meet.
I mean,
with your business skills
and, you know, your connections
and financial backing,
combined with my tenacity
and my addiction to caffeine,
um, it's unstoppable.
(sharks laugh)
Addiction to caffeine.
(laughs)
Have you planned out what you
would do with the $50,000?
It's actually just
going primarily
to building the product.
Do you have an order from
somebody to sell it to them?
Um, I-I don't have
actual P.O.S,
um, 'cause y--I don't want
to promise something
and then something fall through
and not be able to get it.
So, Megan, um...
I have to admire your tenacity,
but this is not really
a business I'm interested in.
I'm out.
You're in
a brutally competitive market.
I mean, anybody, including me,
if I wanted to,
could find a Megan
and get into the soap business,
so the only thing
of Value here is a brand,
which is unproven Yet.
Good luck to you,
and I'm impressed
with your presentation,
but it doesn't make it easy
for me to smell the money.
I'm out.
(inhales deeply)
All right, Megan.
I'm--I'm Teeter-tottering.
I mean, what makes you
the person
to take this
from concept and design
all the way
through to success?
Um, well, I guess
the first, um, example
would be that I decided that
I was gonna give it a go,
and in about a month,
I had international press.
You know, I had magazines
in the states.
"Tatler" In the U.K. Wrote
about me.
But, you know,
that's short-lived.
It doesn't mean you're gonna
continuously get that press,
and it doesn't mean you can
always convert it to sales.
What--what skills
do you have
that are gonna give us
confidence,
or give me confidence to say,
"you know what?
Once We get past the hype,
we can deliver."
Uh, there's nothing
that can stop me.
Trust me.
If you teach me ropes,
and you tell me
what I need to do,
I will get it done,
and you don't even have
to think about it again.
That's what gonna be so great
about working with me.
You don't have
to keep telling me
over and over
and over again.
Like, I know what has
to be done, and I do it.
I--there's just something
in my blood. (chuckles)
I'm sure you guys
understand it.
(laughs)
I... (chuckles)
so?
So for $55,000 for 20%,
we have a deal?
No. Just wait
a minute there.
♪♪♪
Two sharks are out, and Megan
has one offer from Mark.
So for $55,000 for 20%,
we have a deal?
No. Just wait
a minute there.
You're a total surprise.
I wrote you off
the minute you walked in.
Right away, "here comes
a blonde bombshell,"
but the more you talk,
the more I'm convinced
that you're
a real killer.
Thank you. That means a lot
coming from you.
But--
here comes
her bloodsucking offer.
Megan, listen to me
just a minute, all right?
Every Single entrepreneur
that I've invested in
on this show is making money.
Why is that?
Because I work my buns off
making sure they're a success.
When they call me,
they find me immediately.
If your soap is successful,
it's gonna take a lot more money
than $50,000,
so you're not in here
asking for enough.
But I'm gonna give you
the... $55,000,
but I must take...
40% of your business.
Because the truth
of the matter is,
I have to make a return,
and I also need a dime
for every bar you sell.
So if you'll give me
a dime a bar
and you'll give me 40%
of your business for $55,000,
I would love to be
your partner,
and you'll just be
another success Story.
Okay.
I'm gonna start to cry.
And I'd love to have
an answer now.
I--really, I'm so moved.
Don't be--you--
oh, hush. (chuckles)
All that warm and fuzzy stuff
came out to a bloodsucking offer
of 40% of your company.
This is a no-brainer.
My offer is clearly Better.
(inhales deeply and sighs)
Oh, my goodness.
Megan, I can smell
the blood in the water.
You've got Barbara.
You've got, uh, mark circling.
You can also smell
the Lemons, too.
I can smell the Lemons...
(chuckles)
And, uh, most importantly,
I smell your drive.
I didn't write you off.
Thank you. (chuckles)
I don't make a judgment
on how people look,
unlike Barbara...
(chuckles)
Uh...
do you have your own job?
I work, um, for myself
independently
as a graphic designer.
Do you want to do
this full-time?
I--that's why I'm here.
(chuckles)
I think it's
a fantastic product.
a great brand...
thank you.
But my concern is,
are you gonna quit
your other job?
Yeah, I-I pretty much
already have. (chuckles)
Well, pretty much is not
all of it.
Yes. Yes. Already have.
It's said and done. This is--
how will you--how will
you support yourself, though?
This is my life now.
So this is 100%?
I'm sorry?
How will you support yourself
when you quit your other job?
I've been a little chipmunk.
I've been stowing things away
so that I could make this jump.
Megan, look, I've had
a ton of experience
supporting entrepreneurs.
I know what it's like to be
an entrepreneur and starve.
I know what it's like
to have all your dreams
just sitting there
right in front of you,
and you're just
knowing that
if I just had somebody
WHO could help me
and who had been
there before,
they could get me
over the top.
That's who I am.
That's why
I'm sitting here,
and that's why I like to get
involved with people like you.
Here's what I think
you need to do.
I smell success in you.
This is purely
an investment in you.
I think what you need is,
you need some cash flow
to give you the freedom
to make the right decisions.
She is so far--
no, Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You are so far from desperate...
So let me--
you should just be laughing
at that.
No, no, but, Megan,
mark isn't listening.
He's hearing half the story.
I think what the offer
needs to be is,
the business needs
$55,000 for the 20%,
but I think you need
a salary along the way
in the first year.
You have taken this and done
a lot of amazing things.
That's why you're getting
so much interest.
My offer would be to pay you
the $55,000 for the 20%,
but pay you another $50,000
for you to live
in the first 12 months,
so you have the freedom...
(chuckles)
to make the right decisions
and grow the business...
(Kevin) You guys are all nuts.
'cause that's what
I believe in.
This isn't gold bars.
This is soap. This is crazy.
Pick an offer.
I'm gonna edit my offer
for you, all right?
I'll give you the $55,000
for the 30%.
Megan, before--
Megan--
wait. Let me just add
something here.
In the big picture
of things, right,
it's not about the cash.
It's about who's gonna give
you the support.
I can make available time
and experience and access
to my other companies
as well.
I think the money
in the first year is important.
Right now it's about survival.
I think a little extra Cash
is gonna help you
go on the right path,
and I believe in you.
You're gonna get there.
(Barbara) but it's not
an important card here.
You know what's
an important card here?
That you get lined up
with the right distributor.
You're not gonna be
successful
because of
other people's success.
You're gonna be successful
because of your own success.
But let me tell you, women work
Harder, and you know it.
Ohh.
I work circles
around this guy.
Oh, please.
Oh, boy.
Absolutely.
Really?
I-I got here
because I didn't work?
No. Women work Harder
than men.
(imitates violin)
(chuckles)
Put one woman against a man
in any situation...
Please.
She will outwork
the guy anytime.
Girl power.
You know why?
All right.
Enough, enough, enough.
(laughs)
Megan, you gotta make
a call.
What are you going to do?
I love all the offers,
and I love all of you guys.
Um, Barbara, I've always wanted
you to be my business mom...
(chuckles) But starting out
this first couple of years,
money is crucial.
I think I'm going to go
with Robert's deal.
Ohh.
Oh, great decision.
Is that a final decision,
Megan?
(inhales deeply)
Yes.
I would--
I would think twice.
I would think twice
about that final.
Thank you. Thank you.
(laughs)
Congratulations. Great job.
You made a mistake, Megan.
(chuckles)
(Kevin) All of that,
and she just took the money.
It makes me feel
warm and fuzzy Inside.
(mark) Wow.
Choosing between
Those three amazing deals
was really difficult,
but having that extra money
is really what helped tip
the scales,
um, and I think
Robert's going to be
a great business partner for me.